you see this one what's this one Hunter
Biden Slip Sliding naked there's no way
oh this is fantastic
he got a little thing I'm telling you
his Schmidt is actually decent let me
see Ashley
[Laughter]
this guy is hilarious the more videos
I'm seeing of this guy I'm like I kind
of want to hang with him yeah he's a fun
time yeah dude
he might be the white Andrew Tate this
guy's living his best life the world is
watching it yo he looks good for a
crackhead
still got his teeth
this guy's awesome
yeah
he's just playing with he's stretching
out that yeah yeah he's getting it on
medium stuff he's getting ready
you gotta get a camera ready you know I
feel that I respect that 100 he's in the
he might be a patron honestly I want him
to submit a patreon to question let me
see do we have any videos of him
smashing anything oh yeah yeah yeah
there's one of them wait for real yeah
he's beating box yeah he the camera
angle is all [ __ ] up though yeah he
like so this is an interesting one this
is allegedly uh a woman and you got
these ready he was tied up
with a bag over her head doing like some
some bonds of stuff he's also putting
out a sandwich maybe a uh a croissant he
got her in that Portnoy right there he
might have a chocolate croissant also
okay
but maybe this is like a good time she's
she's trying to get over like a carb
addiction or something like that and
this is like we're gonna put as close to
as possible so that you can like an
emergency or it's a fetish I think you
could be helping this girl I think
there's no proof at all that he's doing
some sort of like sadomasochistic ritual
I think that that girl had a serious
like uh she might have buy dysmorphia or
something like that now this is a little
bit more primitive yeah this one is him
with uh two girls that drink Monster
[Laughter]
you got to give a little bit of respect
to what's that the British royal family
I know this is hard for you yeah it is
you too
and me more me than you because my
people went through way more
also this is the schmeet one right here
okay wait hold on hold on
what's that thing next time
but he's just kind of like getting it
stroking meat
wait Ayala over stroker wait what don't
don't put him yeah
Hunter's not a very white white guy
let's be honest yeah but he just
you know he's just overhead with it why
you don't ever hit it with the overnight
I mean yo yo could be a rapper no he's
[ __ ] and he pulls out the Glocks
so he's fully naked he's about to hit it
from the back
he's your new king
come on bro yo do we even need Chet
Hanks anymore no how does
how does real talk like this affects
chess Legacy if he is a Jamaican accent
I don't even think we ever listen to
Chet again Chad got his life together
hey check out his entertainment
this is the real white boy summer
started true white boy Summers